you have written multiple times over the
past couple of years about you know what
what the the experience with the
pandemic and with lockdowns and with
euas and whatnot
um you know how that is it it is setting
the stage or you look forward to a
future where a lot of democratic norms
and a lot of personal Liberty uh
economic Liberty you name it ends how
are you feeling about the kind of health
of the body politic has the you know has
has the covet experience kind of
weakened us so that we're going to be
more sheepish in the future or has it
kind of kicked in a set of kind of
cultural antibodies you were talking
earlier uh with us about how you know
now people are as likely as not to say
screw you to whatever the government
says where are you on this this kind of
concern right now
yeah
um I'm I'm very worried about what's
outlined in that piece and um you know
just think about it uh we still take our
shoes off in the airports I mean I don't
know if that has done anything or has
any net expected value versus the
thousands of hours it has caused an
enormous amount of personal
embarrassment but uh yeah beyond that
beyond that time accomplished much more
than that I mean that is a good thing
for the country to be doing but yeah but
we still do it
um so what's the argument of that piece
the argument is that we have a situation
where who decides that their emergency
Powers end it's the governor it's the
president the president has announced
that this emergency will end in in May
um if you have a situation where an
elected official decides when they get
to have massive powers and they decide
what the emergency is and the media can
shape our impression of the emergency
perhaps with misleading statistics or
misleading anecdotes
um how might that be misused I think the
potential for misuse is tremendous
that that piece outlines a hypothetical
scenario I hope it never happens that
you know the governor of a small state
around an election says Hey the
hospitals are filling up with cases and
we have to declare uh you know we're
gonna see we're gonna stop uh Motor
Vehicles because you know we can't just
have extra car accidents in the hospital
we don't have the space uh or other
restrictions they could place
restrictions that could happen around
voting or election Cycles I think we
have underestimated uh the threat of
these powers to be used by an
unscrupulous actor and I think no matter
where anyone sits on the political
Spectrum you can all imagine somebody
you don't want to have the power to
declare unlimited emergency Powers
um and I think we should be more
cognizant of that this is uh from
February 28 2023 So Yesterday California
just ended that's uh Governor I should I
should be more specific Gavin Newsom
ended the state of emergency because
that's the situation we're in is that
one person has the ability to do that
with no Democratic check on their powers
and and I I agree with with you that
this is a looming threat coming out of
this that needs to be taken seriously
and I hope there's more
um kind of focus and and you know effort
especially at the state and local level
since that's where these things seem to
drag on and on again like why should a
state of emergency be able to just uh
endlessly persist until the person who
declared it says it's over it seems like
there should be you know a regular
check-in maybe from the legislature to
say okay are we really still all on the
same page here I mean I know that the
California legislature has the power to
do that but it's almost got to be like
baked in to the state of emergency
itself or else I I'm afraid that we we
really are going to fall into that sort
of trap whenever the next catastrophe
hits
absolutely right no I couldn't agree
more with you
yeah and that's a place where the kind
of structural reform where you know
every state of emergency no matter what
has a sunset Clause you know whether
it's you know two weeks or 30 days or 90
days or that it has to be renewed
um God you have to do that when you lock
people up you know on on a psychiatric
holds in California you know you gotta
you got to drag them in front of a court
at least to to keep them after a certain
point and the principle there is when
you deprive people of Liberty there must
be some check on your ability to deprive
them of Liberty and what we did in the
pandemic was in many ways we deprived
people of Liberty and some core human
Liberties the Liberty to go and visit
your child when they get chemotherapy
and have both parents be there we
deprive them of that Liberty we deprive
them the Liberty to go to shops and
restaurants and go out uh uh and there
has to be checks on those those sorts of
deprivations we all agree there was a
covid-19 emergency but does anyone think
there's an emergency for healthy 12 to
15 year olds in 2023 February I think
I'd be hard-pressed to find anyone who
can genuinely look you in the eye and
tell you there's an emergency but if you
were to imagine if they're you know
there's people talking about whether or
not there's an escape of bird flu or
something like that if that were really
to happen in this year I think we'll be
it's will be totally destroyed I mean
you'll you'll just see some states doing
the exact opposite of other states
they'll be uh Fierce political
contention around this issue uh they'll
be Revolt from a huge chunk of the
citizenry over any action uh even an
action that is actually the wise action
for a different risk that's totally
different
um people may Revolt over I think we are
so weak and vulnerable
um so you're there's two parts of the
question one is how can they rebuild a
trust trust you lost in a moment takes
decades to reaccumulate the second the
second thing is what can an individual
do
um the second part first what can an
individual do I mean I used to also
trust the CDC and my trust is shattered
and so what that means is every time I
make a personal medical decision I have
to do a lot more homework and so I have
less and less trust and experts and I
don't like to live that way I mean I'd
like to have some trust in institutions
and experts makes my life harder to go
decide if the Bible and booster is right
for me and figure out who I can follow
and not follow and I'm somebody who's
trained in evidence-based medicine you
know um I'm trained in this sort of
stuff but it still work uh so I lament
that and I think we all are going to
have to think of ways that we can work
on that for the building trust back I
think we can talk about some structural
fixes but
um it's it's going to take decades I
mean I think that the harms were done
it's going to take decades uh most of my
fixes are you know the CDC look at their
roles their job is to keep track of the
death statistics and also to tell you
what you ought to do we need separate
groups I mean the people keeping track
of the statistics just keep track of
statistics and Report statistics on a
website that any American can download
they've made mistakes in their
statistics you know they were incorrect
about the number of kids who were dead
and they had to provide a revision and
of course their their errors always go
in the direction of their policy and so
an observer might say this is not a
random error this looks like bias like
you're lying to me to get me to do what
you want me to do and the only way to do
that is to build a firewall so the
people who try to advise you are
different than those keeping the
statistics yeah I think there needs to
be a third Group which is the group that
sets out to evaluate the policies and
they should be separate from the group
that institutes the policies the CDC
says schools should wear masks and by
the way our new study that we published
in our own journal says that that was a
good idea I mean what am I to think I
mean you said to do it you did the study
and you put in your own journal and it
has tons of flaws we need Separate
Checks and Balances in public health
just like we do have in government hey
thanks for watching that excerpt from
our conversation with vinay Prasad about
U.S Public Health mRNA vaccines and
future threats that the president set by
cobit emergency measures might pose to
our civil liberties you can check out
the full conversation by clicking on the
link in the description and catch these
conversations streamed live to reason TV
every Thursday at 1 pm Eastern see you
next time